[Music]
adventure hound reckless goofball big
grin not the brightest bob in the box
these are the descriptors that
immediately come to mind when you think
about monkey d luffy but occasionally
our childlike hero and pirate
extraordinaire does something so crazily
awesome you realize there's more to him
than meets the eye he demands your
respect and admiration and you give it
gladly when it comes to ability and
sheer pluck luffy's got it all he might
not think things through and might get
his crewmates in a tough spot more than
once because of his impulsiveness but
he's also innately kind just brave and
generous he's got all the qualities of a
hero and when he shows this side of his
character the only way to describe him
is badass paying tribute to these heroic
quantities here are the top 10 badass
luffy moments in one piece
at number 10 luffy shows us what a
terrifying monster he can be by knocking
out 50 000 fish man pirates with his
conquerors haki while luffy used this
unique form of haki which only a chosen
few can wield on several occasions
throughout the series his display on
fishman island is amongst the most
memorable it's not just the numbers he
defeats but also his prowess at using
this god-given power the slack-jawed
look of shock and surprise on hodi's
face says all there is to say of the
impact luffy has on the enemy's morale
with this show of strength luffy's
actions have an immediate and deep
impact while his battle with hody goes
the whole hog and even gives him some
trouble this early moment shows that
luffy's victory is but inevitable
[Music]
next up is luffy one shotting bellamy in
the gyre arc
before his rather unexpected and moving
character progression in the dress
russell arc benemi's a small time thug
whose arrogance cynicism and all-round
bad behavior make him insufferable he's
called bellamy the hyena and he lives up
to his nickname emulating the animal's
physical features and opportunistic
tendencies in jaya bellamy picks a fight
with luffy in a bar when luffy in a rare
show of maturity refuses to engage in a
meaningless brawl bellamy beats up and
humiliates the straw hat captain and
zorro but nobody beats up luffy and gets
away with it it's just not done bellamy
gets his comeuppance when luffy one
shots him in the middle of town knocking
him out cold and shutting him up for
good right in the middle of his springy
dance it's an intensely satisfying punch
one that even saitama would be proud of
coming in at number eight is luffy's
revelation of gear fourth bound man
well it's a pleasure to watch luffy go
from strength to strength with each gear
fourth gear is the most visually
arresting of the lot in the bruising
battle against don quixote doflamingo
luffy goes into gear forth by biting
down on his forearm and inflating his
body with air to resemble a giant
balloon while also enhancing his muscle
strength the transformation is dramatic
as it is but series creator ichiro oda
makes it even more fantastic with the
addition of some kabuki style theatrics
in the fight luffy uses the fourth gear
technique bound man which allows him to
bounce up and down and gain incredible
speed and power it's the perfect counter
to dophie who's no lightweight in the
power department
[Applause]
[Music]
for the next badass moment we have luffy
doing what he does best making a
spectacle of himself in the most
unconventional manner
the watershed battle of marineford to
save ace from being executed by the
marines begins in earnest when luffy
falls from the sky from an upturned boat
a bunch of rag tag allies on his heels
the sight of luffy and his noisy crew
free-falling into the fight arena sends
shockwaves throughout the marines and
pirates down below considering how the
battle ends this entrance is both
comical and irreverent the complete
opposite of whitebeard's epic entrance a
little earlier in the day the
lightheartedness of it all prevents any
foreshadowing of the darkness and
tragedy that's just about to come in
fact luffy brings with him a sense of
hope that all will be well but despite
everything that happens luffy's grand
entrance can never be forgotten
[Music]
at number six we have luffy
sucker-punching kaido in his dragon form
in their very first meeting in muano
if there's anything luffy excels at it's
being impulsive and doing the opposite
of what he should be doing after the
lord luffy alliance arrives in wano the
strategy they adopt is to keep a low
profile and work in secrecy to bring
down the yonko but their plans go up in
smoke as luffy not only reveals himself
to kaido in a fit of rage but also
chases him down and lands a punch on him
powerful enough to slam him senseless
into the ground troop kaido is drunk as
a skunk when he's bought down by a
single hit to the head but the fact that
kaido is in his dragon form at this
moment is a testimony to luffy's power
and bravado it also raises the
anticipation sky high for the duo's
final clash which should definitely be
worth the wait
in the fifth spot is luffy using
conquerors haki during the battle of
marineford
as the executioner's blades come down on
ace and the situation looks dire luffy
unleashes this incredible power failing
the killers of most of the pirates and
marines this haki display is totally
different from the one of fishman island
for one luffy's actions in marineford
are unconscious born out of desperation
to save his brother even as those around
him are stunned luffy is completely
unaware of what he's done secondly he
manages to subdue a much more powerful
crowd compared to the fishman pirates
the marineford gang is made up of some
of the fiercest pirates and toughest
marines it's safe to say this is the
moment luffy officially announces his
arrival in the new world
[Music]
next up is luffy declaring war on the
world government in ennis lobby
the ark to rescue robin from the cp9 a
group of assassins on the government's
payrolls is one of the most heartfelt in
the entire series it really captures the
spirit of the theme of nakama that runs
through one piece like blood in the
veins usop in his so gay king disguise
puts in an mvp performance as he on
luffy's orders shoots down the world
government symbol of power its flag with
a fiery slingshot the burning flag is a
burning example of just how far luffy
and his crew are willing to go for one
of their own and for what they believe
to be just and right this moment comes
early in the series but it's such a
powerful one it can't be forgotten in a
hurry
number three is luffy facing off against
the three admirals in the marineford arc
which as you would have realized by now
is a minefield of impactful moments
the three admirals aokiji akainu and
kizaru are the true symbols of the
navy's power each gifted with the devil
fruit power so mighty that they're a
threat to the fiercest pirates going up
against even one of them could mean
certain defeat maybe even death and yet
luffy is neither afraid nor hesitant
when he pole vaults his way to get in
their collective face he's clearly
exhausted from fighting his way through
weak from the sea water and desperate to
save ace but his glaring eyes show no
fear on the other hand the terror on
aces face makes it all too clear what
great danger luffy might have landed
himself in thanks to this poster worthy
moment we can't wait for that inevitable
final clash between luffy and the
marines top brass
[Music]
in the runner-up spot is luffy
challenging big mom for the second time
[Music]
isn't the kind of woman you make an
enemy of even by accident she not only
has one of the most fearsome devil fruit
powers she's also extremely cruel
tyrannical and unpredictable luffy who
knows no fear has had a hostile
relationship with her from the get-go he
first picks a fight with her without
ever having laid eyes on her but it's
his second challenge that leaves all
witnesses to the seed including the
yonko herself speechless this one too
like the first one takes place over den
den denmushi captured and jailed on
whole cake island luffy not only mocks
big mom for her controlling ways and her
ambition of becoming the king of pirates
but he also vows to take back sanji and
have the last laugh in their contest
from how it looks it's clearly a case of
an ant challenging an elephant the look
of outrage and incredulous belief on big
mom's face says it all
[Music]
punching its way straight to the top of
the list is luffy punching a celestial
dragon this is the moment that defines
luffy as the upstart who's not afraid of
anyone not least of those undeservedly
holding on to positions of great power
and influence it also shows how deeply
luffy cares for his friends how little
he cares for an established order that
discriminates against certain people and
how he has his own strong sense of
justice the slow walk up the stairs of
the auction house where the snively
saint chalos has just shot hachi simply
for fun is now iconic so is the
dangerous look in luffy's eyes before he
unleashes that swinging punch smack dab
into noble's face in the one piece
universe the celestial dragons are
portrayed as weak yet powerful
privileged yet irresponsible cruel and
lacking compassion to see one of their
worst get his just desserts is such
sweet satisfaction that it's luffy who
enforces this much needed justice makes
him that much more badass
and that's it for the top 10 badass
luffy moments in one piece if you like
this video you know what to do next
don't you press the like button and
share the video with your friends you
can also subscribe to my channel vinnie
tube for more one piece and anime
related top 10s and videos there's
plenty to choose from share your
thoughts in the comments below and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you